detroit down to houston
and new york to venerate
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that life to me
there ain't no doubt i love this land
god bless the usa
[Music]
i know i'm free and
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
but your raids go down i love this land
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a lot of people that's look at
that
that's incredible i hope the fake news
media is turning their cameras way
way back there that's incredible
hello omaha
and i have to also say because a lot of
people are here from
iowa hello iowa
okay wait a minute who's from iowa race
go
who's from omaha
you know what we're going to be in iowa
soon we'll do that one separately
that's a big difference seven days from
now we're going to
win nebraska
and we're going to win four more years
in the great white house that beautiful
beautiful way
[Applause]
this is look at this i can't believe
this
29 000 people can you believe
29 000 you know we have to win both
nebraska's you know that right you have
two you cut
we're going to win both this election is
a choice
between the trump super recovery which
is what we're having
or a biden depression sad to say
and some bad news just came out on biden
but i won't tell you about that you'll
find that out tomorrow
oh look at you man that's something
biden has pledged the biggest tax hike
in the history of our country first man
that i've ever seen campaign on the fact
i'm going to raise your taxes what's
going on
i gave working families record-setting
tax cuts
and in my second term i will cut
middle-class taxes
very substantially more
[Applause]
and by the way a lot of things are going
on you're seeing those poll numbers
they're going through the roof i hate to
tell
[Applause]
where is the fake news it's over there
oh that's a lot of cameras
oh it's going up they're very concerned
they're very very concerned all over
florida's looking great
now nebraska we know it's looking great
okay
i mean in theory i didn't really have to
be here but it's nice to be with your
friends too
with your vote we will continue to bring
back our jobs support our police
defend our second amendment which is
under siege
[Music]
secure our borders maintain american
energy independence
expand school choice
and ensure more products are proudly
stamped with the phrase
that beautiful phrase beautiful phrase
made in the usa right
i will deliver record prosperity epic
job growth and a safe vaccine that
eradicates the virus and quickly ends
the pandemic
and we're making that final turn they
don't want to hear
it we're making that turn you know that
right
we're going to have the vaccine anyway
with or without it
we're making the turn normal life will
fully
resume that's all we want we want normal
life
normal life go back seven months we'll
take normal life greatest economy we
ever had
we want normal life and next year will
be the greatest economic year
in the history of our country that's
where we're heading
super me joe biden doesn't even respect
you enough to campaign he never came
here right did he come here
oh all right so that's the end of that
i'll see you guys moments ago we learned
about the other reason joe biden has
been hiding in his basement in a
national
television interview do you want me to
tell you the rest
[Applause]
the biden family's business partner
revealed shocking disturbing and
explosive information about joe biden's
corrupt
and illicit foreign business dealings
while he was vice president
the business partner made clear that
biden's denial of involvement
in his son's corrupt business dealings
was a blatant lie with proof
he stated with first-hand knowledge that
vice president biden
was directly and personally involved in
establishing
corrupt business dealings with china and
getting money for it
this all happened at the same time as
biden was letting
china steal american jobs and plunder
american wealth you saw that for eight
years
if biden wins china wins and china
will own the usa if biden wins he will
do bad things by the way
he's not a good guy just so you
understand
[Music]
[Applause]
is there any place you would rather be
than a trump rally on about a 10 degree
evening 10 degrees
it's cold out here but that's okay you
know we just left wisconsin it was cold
and we left michigan it was called and
raining
and i said i won't put on a hat because
i'm going to show you how tough we are
that was a tough one
it was pouring it was pouring and it was
freezing and it's the coldest right here
i hate to tell you well it's a little
later
it's an honor to be with you i have to
say when we win
you win nebraska wins and all of america
wins and that's the way we are
[Applause]
joe biden spent the last 47 years
think of it 47 47 years
outsourcing your jobs opening your
borders
and sacrificing american blood and
treasure
in endless foreign ridiculous wars
countries you've never even heard of in
2016
nebraska voted to fire this corrupt
political establishment and you elected
an
outsider as president who finally
put america first
[Applause]
and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician
if i don't always play by the rules of
the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and i fought harder for you
than any president who's ever held this
wonderful beautiful office that i can
tell you
this election is a matter of economic
survival
for omaha and for communities all across
our country
joe biden's agenda and i'm not sure it's
zoe biden's agenda let's face it
it's not his agent it sounds nice
spiders degenerate the guy's shot
he's shot he's so gonzo you saw him
yesterday
he took him away i was in pennsylvania
with these tremendous like crowds like
this
at tremendous rallies and he had the lid
on right you know they live like from a
garbage can they call it they live
and they saw what was happening because
i went to three of them i did three of
them yesterday in pennsylvania
so he went from delaware to the closest
point where pennsylvania hits delaware
which was about five minutes away from
his basement
and he made a speech just before that he
called me george he said george i think
he was talking about george
and his wife was sitting next to home
and she you could see she was not happy
but it's hard to correct them you know
the camera's on but he called me george
and then he did the
little speech and it wasn't good they
sort of just moved him out they took him
away his own people brush them off they
took them off stage
this is not what you can have you know
we have the greatest country in the
world we have more potential than any
country in the world
we can't play games
we can't play again so the democrats
let's say the democrats the radical left
democrats
they have an extreme agenda he's just a
vehicle he'll be there for about four
weeks or so and then you'll have
kamala kamala it's not going to be
that will not be the first woman
president you're going to have a woman
president
maybe soon maybe soon but you're not
going to have kamala
can't be kamala she's further left
by far than crazy bernie you know bernie
is
like a conservative compared to her
but biden's extreme agenda includes a
radical vision to destroy
suburbs across our nation how are your
suburbs doing
don't ask are they good they won't be
good for longer thinking
and to completely dismantle law
enforcement and [ __ ] police
departments nationwide you know what's
going on you see it better than anybody
you don't have to take my word for it
biden's plan
to destroy suburbs and police just take
a look
roll the tape we do this view of this
freezing cold night
[Music]
the suburbs today are not the suburbs of
half a century ago the suburbs are
far more diverse than the cities but
they're being
targeted being targeted for what
federalized centralized government
control
by the left democrats want to abolish
the suburbs they are too clean and nice
and therefore by definition they are
racist the biden campaign has highly
specific plans
on how to do this it's called
affirmatively furthering fair housing
it's a hud regulation
it was written during the obama
administration biden's advisors plan to
enforce it
towns will be ordered to abolish zoning
for single-family housing
because single-family homes needless to
say are racist
low-income federally subsidized
apartments will go up in the suburbs
we'll also build 1.5 million new
energy-efficient homes
and public housing units
thankfully trump repealed this rule back
in july
but now the left is backing an even more
radical plan
it was a bill put forward by senator
cory booker to push low-income housing
developments
into the suburbs this would be a federal
takeover
of local zoning laws in essence and
biden
he fully supports it
the prior administration piled up more
than 600
major new regulations a cruel and
punishing regulatory burden that cost
the
average american an additional two
thousand
three hundred dollars per year think of
that the average american
two thousand three hundred dollars
regulation
hitting low-income americans by far the
hardest
our historic regulatory relief is
providing the average american household
an extra
three thousand one hundred dollars every
single year
i've had the luxury of enjoying the
benefit of the tax cuts
the tax cuts allowed me to grow my
businesses i believe that if you
take into account the trump tax cut
you take into account the drop in
unemployment and particularly
unemployment for african americans the
lowest it's ever been in history how's
the economy right now
we're loving it kennedy credits the
trump tax cuts and deregulation for her
company's growth it's the first time
in 10 years that it's booming again the
tax cuts
that uh were imposed did wonders
for the the middle class i will cut
taxes even further
for hardworking moms and dads i will not
raise taxes i will cut them
first thing i do is gonna repeal this
trump tax cut
[Music]
do you believe there is systemic racism
in law enforcement
absolutely i've been a police officer
for nearly 32 years
joe biden does not have the backs of
police officers
joe biden's staffers that gave money to
a fund
to help bail out accused criminals joe
biden's silence is encouraging the
rioters
kamala harris was working to help the
instigators the criminals get out of
jail
if joe biden's elected it's just going
to continue everyone to be aware
because they're not going to stop
the only person that defended the police
is trump i have had overwhelming support
from
police my whole career up until this
year we can reduce the responsibilities
assigned to the police and redirect some
of the funding for police do we agree
that we can redirect some of the funding
yes absolutely in joel biden's america
will all be in danger if you support the
police and you want to be safe in your
home and you want your children safe
support donald trump
thank you very much well that's pretty
effective you know what that costs to
bring to you
thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
pretty effective right you see it it
saves me a lot of words i can sit here
watch i say see
nah he's not the right guy he's not the
right guy he's not right for this
country
he's not he's not the guy for this
country this election
is a choice between the american dream
which is what we want
and a socialist nightmare which is where
you would head
if you ever did that which i don't
believe you'll do it's a choice between
a trump
boom and a biden lockdown he wants to
lock it all down
no we close it up we understand the
disease
it's a terrible thing should never have
been allowed to come here from china
should never have been allowed joe biden
will delay the vaccine
postpone therapies prolong the pandemic
shutter your schools right shutter use
schools
destroy your small businesses and shut
down
our country we're not doing that look we
are setting records 11.4 million people
it's all opened up
we understand it and we are doing a job
we are literally setting records on
employment
look at housing look at automobile
production
look at how you're doing in nebraska
look at how you're doing in nebraska
biden even wants to lock down young and
healthy americans yet
for those under the age of 50 i hate to
say this
under the age of 50 how many are under
the age of 50.
pretty young well i have good news for
you
99.99 okay you know what that means that
means you're in good shape that's what
that means
but you notice the fake news now right
all they talk about is kovit kovetkovit
kovetkovan and we've made such progress
it's incredible
excuse me i'm here
i mean i wasn't exactly feeling great
it's been a long time i wasn't exactly
feeling great
and i met with the great doctors one
thing when you're president you got
plenty of doctors
we have one of them here tonight i think
right we have our great white house
doctors traveling sean he's become very
famous
where's sean he's become oh is that sean
look at sean
look at him wow
you know he's got a big ego he loves it
when i mention his thing
now he's a great doctor and they were
great doctors from johns hopkins and
from
walter reed and everything else and uh
what we know today
is like so different than what we knew
six months ago
incredible the progress they've made and
with the vaccines which are coming
immediately even without we're turning
that corner
you know at some point we're turning
that corner and it's been pretty amazing
uh
florida had a rough time boom it's step
back
it's all the way down texas all the way
down
arizona great governors all the way down
biden's cruel and senseless lockdowns
would cause
countless deaths from suicide drug
overdose
and delayed medical care alcohol
i mean so many so many different
problems remember i'd say
the cure cannot be worse than the
problem itself
that's what you have when i banned
travel from
china remember he said now he says oh we
should have done it sooner except when i
banned it
for two and a half months he said he
shouldn't do that he's xenophobic right
and now he says oh i should have done it
earlier
and he had a thing called the swine flu
it was a disaster
much less lethal he was a it was a
disaster he was a disaster
he's still a disaster actually if we
listen to joe
countless more people would have died
they were anticipating it could be
2.2 million you don't hear that 2.2
million
and you know the number it's still one
is too many as far as i'm concerned
one is too many this shouldn't have
happened one is too many
but it could have been 2.2 it could have
been more than that
biden was willing to sacrifice your
lives
on the altar of open borders he wants
open borders
without borders you don't have
without borders you don't have a country
by the way the wall is now
over 400 miles long
and we're building 10 miles a week and
it's very soon going to be finished so
we have the strongest southern border
we've ever had
and we want people to come into our
country but they have to come in legally
and they have to come in through merit
merit
biden has no plan no idea no clue he has
no clue that's for sure and he just
wants to
lock up and throw away the keys letting
riders and looters run wild
and you know it's interesting they call
them peaceful protesters
they burn down your cities they do
things that nobody's seen before
all in radical left democrat run
cities and states but cities all of them
all of them and every time we go in we
were going to go into seattle we let
them know we're coming in
the night before we came in they gave up
they left they took over a piece of
seattle that wasn't going to last
minneapolis the same thing we went into
minneapolis
we went in you know we have to be asked
in theory by the state
we went into minneapolis and it all
ended it took about
what do you think 25 minutes or so it
was just boom
right down the street now you know the
republican-run cities are doing very
well
the republican run cities
and i hope you agree because i know he's
here but you have a very good
republican governor you do know that
right
[Applause]
listen to that good good hi pete
good pete i'm glad they did that did i
want to do the
otherwise i just wouldn't introduce you
later you know keep it quiet
they like you pete the biden plan will
crush you
and crush your family my plan will crush
the virus and you will see economic
benefits like we've never seen
in our country before that's where we're
handled
when the china plague arrived we moved
heaven and earth
to fight the disease we airlifted
medical supplies
pioneered groundbreaking therapies
reduced the
fatality rate 85 think of that
and saved over 2 million lives our
excess mortality rate
has been 42 less than europe you hear
about europe
42 less much better than europe
i'm working to make the breakthrough
treatment that i received
i did i had this thing called regeneron
i don't know i'd like to say it had
nothing to do i'd like to say
my immune system is just like barren
trump
you know first lady had it i had it
baron had it they said sir baron has
tested positive
like 12 minutes later i said how's baron
doing oh he's okay now sir he threw it
away
he just took that through it away you
know they're young
they have strong immune systems but i'd
like to say the treatment didn't do
anything for me
doctor do you hear that didn't i just
threw it away like baron but you know
what
i wasn't gonna take my chance i said you
have something give it to me
and it was effective because i woke up
the next morning after being with these
doctors
they wanted to touch every single part
of your body and i didn't like it
12 of it each one was a specialist right
every single one but they were great no
they were great but i woke up the next
morning
and i tell you i felt like get me out of
here
it was amazing so i really think this
thing
was great that's great i think it was
great
and you know i don't have the luxury of
staying in a basement i'm president
of the united states i don't i can't be
staying i really can't
you can't stay i had a lot of meetings i
meet a lot of people
as president i have that obligation so
we have basements in the white house i
could say we have beautiful bedrooms
upstairs at the white house i could stay
for a year
and a half i can't do that i have to be
working for you and if something happens
that happens
and i get you know they came in they
said uh
sir you've tested positive i said tested
positive for
what then you go into one of the 27
different names corona
there's this china virus the china
plague
the china plank that's what i tested
positive for but it was amazing and it
was actually an experience and
until i came along you were supposed to
have lifetime immunity right
i said well you know i'm recovered i
feel great and i'm immune i could jump
right into this road i could kiss every
man
and woman
[Applause]
but because it was me the press said no
it's not for a lifetime it's only for
four months the immunity is only now for
four months
they brought it down right it was always
going to be for a lifetime now it's four
months so what are you gonna do
what are you going to do it's one of
those things but i guarantee you this
on november 4th you won't be hearing as
much about this it's going to be right
now it's
it's kovind kovitkova no matter what
happens covet coven
and on november 4th you'll probably try
and find some information about it no
we're rounding the term
we're rounding that beautiful turn and
it's going to be
very good the vaccines are going to make
it go away a lot faster
and they're going to be great the
greatest companies the greatest
companies of their kind in the world are
doing it
really good johnson and johnson moderna
they really are great pfizer thanks to
our relentless efforts
97 of all current emergency room
visits are for something other than the
virus think of that 97
we're in great shape and in the one
areas of midwest the little
areas in the midwest certain areas that
are heated up right now they'll go down
they'll go down very quickly they'll be
down within
two weeks they're figuring they'll go
down just like they did in florida texas
arizona and so many others we're on
track to deliver 100 million doses of a
safe vaccine
and a great vaccine and that's all set
we're all set logistically our military
is going to deliver it
it'll be done very quickly we will
vanquish the vaccine and
we will get rid of this whole thing we
will get rid of this virus
it'll be very you watch it's going to
happen
very quickly and we're going to have our
country back
and the whole world is going to be
coming back this was a terrible terrible
thing that happened
terrible thing that happened
terrible thing that happened joe biden
has made a corrupt bargain in exchange
for
his party's nomination he has handed
control of his party over to the
rage-filled
socialists marxists and left-wing
extremists and could we put another name
in there starts with the c
communists yes no we got a couple of
them too unfortunately if biden wins
the flag burning extremists on the
streets
will be running your government it's not
going to happen by the way
by the way just so you know we are so
far you listen to the fakers back there
look at them
you listen to the fake news we are so
far
ahead this is gonna be bigger than four
years ago by the way get out and vote
you gotta that's the only thing
i mean i'm standing here freezing
i ask you one little favor get the hell
out
and vote the great
red wave
at least you're down there with each
other i'm all up here and that wind is
blowing
this election day you must stop the
anti-american radicals and
really i mean that's what they are
they're radicals we can solve these
problems so quickly
if the governments would just say would
you please come in federal government
we stop it in a matter of minutes it
goes so fast
the radicals delivering joe biden you
have to do this
you have to deliver them a message the
far left
a thundering defeat at the ballot box
on november 3rd
[Applause]
it's got to be a big one we got to win
big and we're going to win big you know
i'm watching them and they're getting
like three weeks ago i don't know they
were doing these fake polls and they
felt very good
and then a week ago they were feeling
okay
they're not feeling so good right now
they're saying these are not good
numbers
was that one of the greatest evenings
ever
four years ago
and you know the difference is and i say
this is easier there's more
look at this crowd i mean we had big
crowds we'd never had crowds like this
look at this crowd 29 000.
you you know you have 29 you have 29 000
people in
omaha that's pretty good and you're all
on television
say hello you're on national television
see all the red lights that means the
cameras are going
that means those cameras are going 29
000 people they say
29 000. yeah
you know who spoke today president
barack hussein obama
[Music]
he had 12 people in seven cars did you
hear them
no he draws he draws flies i've never
seen he just
he had no he had no people i thought
he'd have some people
and he brought bon jovi along you know
what happened to bon jovi
they increased the crowd by 22 people
can you believe it
and then joe spoke and that crowd left
and we have 29 000 people here and we
had a tremendous crowd in michigan
and a tremendous crowd in wisconsin
and they're trying to figure out like if
trump is getting these crowds and if
biden's getting like 12 people you know
the circles he fills in the circles they
got like five of them
and a lot of times they put reporters in
there because they have no people
but today he tried to blame that on
covet also
he said no no we don't seek large crowds
because we want it because of the the
virus right they don't want the large
crowd
that's not the reason okay just that's
not the reason
it's a hell of an excuse but it's not
the reason
we're thrilled to be joined by the man
we were just talking about he's a friend
of mine
he loves his state he loves his country
and he's a great governor pete
ricketts pete great job
great job what a good guy what a good
man
how's your state doing pete all right
good how are we doing by the way we're
going to be okay here right
he says good good thank you very much
pete
and his brother todd another one really
good now there's only two people that
are better
joe and marlene now todd is great but
they will both admit
joe and marlene are better right and
you're here
hi joe i like the hat hi joe
you got to be proud of you boys they're
doing a great job thank you very much
thank you very much great family here as
well our
senators deb fisher who is fantastic
[Applause]
she is my favorite senator from the
state
of nebraska
[Applause]
by far by far she's fantastic
she is i'll tell you what she calls me
it doesn't stop
between her and joni ernst for from iowa
who i think is here where's joni
joni joni
they call sir we need help with ethanol
sir
we need help with corn we need it's
always but you know what that's what a
great senator that's what a great
representative supposed to do
right joni thank you very much and i
heard you're doing very well i just saw
some very nice numbers
and deb you don't have to worry about
numbers right
you don't have to worry about numbers
i'm with you all the time thank you both
and uh yeah it looks very good in iowa
thank you very much
and representatives jeff fortenberry
a warrior where's jeff
[Applause]
thank you jeff great great guy don
bacon
what's this wow
wow well i like him too but i don't know
if i like him that much
it's very good
i'll tell you you better get me omaha do
you understand that i said
now i know i wouldn't have asked her but
now i'm going to say make sure we win
this site too
right good how we doing donna here good
huh
good i'm very impressed that's about as
good as i've heard in a long time
and adrian smith thank you
great great job great job great to have
you here
it's a great group of people and these
are warriors they fought with me a lot
they fought with me we just we we
we keep winning over there but it's not
easy right
but we get it gets easier and easier all
the time thank you very much i
appreciate it
for decades our politicians spent
trillions and trillions of dollars
rebuilding foreign nations fighting
foreign wars and defending
foreign borders but now we are finally
protecting our nation
rebuilding our cities and we are
bringing
our jobs our factories and our troops
back home to the usa our troops are
coming home
thank you no our troops are coming back
home it's enough
19 years in afghanistan and we have it
worked and they're coming home
and it's a great thing and they're home
from syria
they're home i left some because we kept
the oil if you don't mind there was some
oil
we captured it we kept it and uh
coming home from iraq it's enough it's
enough we want to
have them all home we have a lot of
other countries too we're in many many
many countries
most of which you never even heard of
right you never even heard of it's
ridiculous
i ended the and by the way making our
military stronger
by far than ever before
i ended the nafta nightmare and proudly
signed the brand new
usmca which is turning out to be
phenomenal it's a great deal it's a
great deal just kicked in now
and you know what companies will not be
leaving
nebraska and iowa and all of our places
there's a very big disincentive for them
to do that
when china targeted our farmers i
delivered 28 billion dollars to our
incredible farmers here in nebraska
and iowa and all across the country
don't forget to tell the people of iowa
that please
28 billion i said to secretary sonny
pertu
of agriculture you know sonny is great i
said sonny
how much were the farmers targeted and
he said 12 billion sir and 16 million
two years 12 and 16.
i said 28 good so i tariffed
28 billion took it from china and
distributed it to our farmers nobody
else
nobody else is gonna do that
in fact some people say our farmers do
better now than they did when they
actually had a farm
but we did we had the biggest order of
corn
two weeks ago in the history of our
country the biggest order of soybeans
and the biggest beef order right two
weeks ago
two weeks ago joe biden's running mate
the most liberal member of the
u.s senate you know that is right
sponsors the insane green new deal
100 trillion dollars you too can have
no windows in your buildings which would
wipe out the ethanol
industry joni it would totally wipe out
that industry we worked hard on that
industry
and they're now in good shape
devastating nebraska and devastating
iowa
as president i will always defend
ethanol okay all right
does nebraska like ethanol too by the
way
[Applause]
okay good i want to just i need that
little assurance
i need that little bit of assurance
under my leadership we achieved the most
secure border in u.s history our
southern border
largely because of the wall my
opponent's insane
immigration plan would completely
eliminate u.s borders open borders they
want to have let's have open borders
so everyone can just pour it like they
used to
he would make every community into a
sanctuary city for violent criminals
so we invested 2.5
trillion dollars a lot of it right here
from this state and
from germany from iowa 2.5 trillion
dollars
new equipment our military is in the
best shape it's ever been in we have the
greatest equipment
anywhere in the world we are the envy of
every other country
russia china north korea
we have the best missiles and rockets
and tanks and
planes and fighter jets f-35s
submarines and our nuclear weapons are
now renovated and or new and fixed
and we only hope to god we never have to
use them hope to god
our military was very much in bad shape
it was depleted it was depleted it was
exhausted it was ridiculous
we killed the leader of isis al-baghdadi
they were looking for
and we took out the world's top
terrorist
solomani is dead i withdrew from the
last administration's
disastrous and ridiculous iran nuclear
deal 150 billion dollars
we paid we paid for nothing and 1.8
billion dollars in cash i'm more
impressed with that what do you think
pop i think i'm more impressed
150 billion or 1.8 billion in cash
i think i'm more impressed with the cash
you ever hear everything like that
that's what we gave to iran for nothing
we got nothing
i recognized the true capital of israel
and opened the american
embassy in jerusalem
and i also recognized israeli
sovereignty over the golan heights
think of that they worked on that for
52 years i got it done in two hours
and instead of never-ending wars in the
middle east
you see what's happening already three
countries that we have five lined up and
we're gonna have another
it's gonna be it's an easy one it's a
lot easier than
you would think they worked on this for
35 years they had the wrong people
they had the wrong concepts but
you know i got nominated for three nobel
peace prizes can you believe it
and for all different regions like
kosovo and serbia we're doing deals you
know trade deals just normally we're
doing trade deals
i said wait a minute aren't they always
fighting each other yeah aren't they
always killing each other yeah for many
decades or how did you know
i said i know they're killing camp they
fight each other all the time
tell them we're not going to do any
business with them they want our
business right
and we're not going to do any business
unless we make a deal where they stop
killing each other
and you know what it took about 20
minutes they've been fighting for 40
years
i think they've been fighting for 400
years you want to know that but they've
been fighting for a long time
they want to make a deal all of a sudden
two months ago they're in the oval
office
hug into two prime minutes hugging and
kissing and thinking great
that was easy joe right that was easy it
just makes sense
i just said hey why don't we get them
together i mean we're gonna do these two
deals
tell them to stop fighting and we save a
lot of lives that's a good thing
but we're forging peace in the middle
east without blood all over the sand and
we're not spending money you're doing it
either it's something very nice
because we're pulling out a vote for
republicans
is a vote for the american dream it's a
vote
for acknowledgement that abraham lincoln
was a republican is that nice people
don't know that
a lot of people don't know so in
conclusion over the next four years we
will make america into the manufacturing
superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
and that's already begun
largely already
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will defend religious liberty free
speech
the right to life and the right to keep
and bear arms
[Applause]
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength and that's what we have now
with what we have
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency that's bigger than
health care you watch
already signed kicks in on january 1st
lower drug prices even more we sign
favored nations
that means we're going to get the lowest
price anywhere in the world right now
we're by far the highest
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation to land
an astronaut on mars and nasa
is the number one space center anywhere
in the world
again it was a mess three and a half
years ago
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and restore patriotic education to our
school
we will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect
our great american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto in god
we trust
[Music]
[Applause]
for years you had a president who
apologized to america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
nebraska and iowa
[Applause]
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors and get your co-workers
get your boss and say boss get out of
here boss
get out and vote you got to vote the red
wave is coming the great
red wave now we're doing very well those
early ballots you know the whole ballot
hoax you see what's going on there's so
much
so many bad things happening but we're
doing very well you know we're supposed
to be a little behind and then we're a
little bit above
right but that wave comes and now we go
to the front of everything
i think we're going to win everything we
didn't come this far
and fight this hard to surrender our
country back to the corrupt
washington swamp
so on november 3rd we must finish the
job that we started
we have done a job like nobody there has
been no
administration nobody but and it's us
all together
there has been no administration has
done in the first
three and a half years what this
administration
has done not even close
[Applause]
not even close from norfolk to hastings
from grand island to lincoln
and from scott's bluff to right here in
omaha
[Music]
[Applause]
we inherit the legacy of nebraska
patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears for
this
beloved nation we stand on the shoulders
of american heroes
who crossed the ocean settled the
continent
tamed the wilderness laid down the
railroads raised up the great
skyscrapers
won two world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and made america the single greatest
nation
in the history of the world and the best
is yet
to come
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country
we are returning power to you the
american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning winning
[Applause]
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of nebraska
and iowa
we have made america powerful again
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you nebraska thank you
iowa thank you both thank you
get out and vote
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can
[Music]
it's
[Music]
[Music]
you can do whatever you feel
young
[Music]
but you've got to know this
[Music]
[Music]
ymca i'm sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
they have
you can hang out with all my boys
[Music]
[Music]
someone came up to me and said the man
[Music]
it's fun to stay at the ymca
it's time
to say i've ever think
[Music]
pick yourself off the ground
young man
[Music]
[Music]
i was down
[Music]
lady
[Music]
smile
[Music]
you must have seen us
dancing in the sand
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
[Music]
jesus freed
[Music]
[Music]
turning back
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
she sings the song
[Music]
the way she knows
[Music]
when i stand softly
[Music]
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh today
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Music]
my
you marry a music man
in the sand
now she's in me
always in my hand
[Music]
oh i would feel sorry
[Music]
when i say softly
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
on the highway
[Music]
today
[Music]
on the highway